innenminister herbert reul hat sich
erschüttert gezeigt über diesen
polizeiskandal in seinem bundesland
insgesamt wird gegen knapp 30 polizisten
ermittelt der vorwurf wir haben es
gerade gehört volksverhetzung und das
verwenden von kennzeichen
verfassungswidriger organisationen
der staatsschutz hat heute morgen bei
mehr als zehn polizisten die wohnungen
durchsuchen lassen und handys
beschlagnahmt
mehr details dazu kennt mein kollege
frank schneider mir nun zugeschaltet
frank wie genau ist der staatsschutz
jetzt überhaupt auf die spur der beamten
gekommen
ja ich muss sagen die pressekonferenz
aus der wir eben das zitat gesehen haben
von herbert reul läuft hinter mir immer
noch es herrscht dort wirklich blankes
entsetzen darüber was vorgefallen ist
tiefer erschütterung und man muss sagen
die aktie heute morgen begann um 6 uhr
es wurden insgesamt 34 wohnungen und
polizei waren durchsucht dort wo die
polizeibeamten arbeiten um dann das
nochmal aufzuschlüsseln 29 beamte sind
insgesamt zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
beschuldigten besteht es könnten noch
mehr werden
wenn jetzt weitere handys ausgewertet
werden zum anderen sind elf beamte sogar
strafrechtlichen ermittlungen ausgesetzt
das heißt die volksverhetzung und eben
dieses von verfassungsfeindlichen
kennzeichen handelt es sich es ist hier
heute geschildert worden um hakenkreuz
flaggen um reichskriegsflagge um hitler
der oder personen die den hitlergruß
zeigen dazu kommt volksverhetzung
es muss wohl ein ganz schlimmes und wo
ein mann mit einem gewehr einen farbigen
jungen tötete zum gleich sind
flüchtlinge zu sehen auf mehrere weniger
konstruieren fotos die in die gaskammern
geführt werden also schon wirklich wie
soll das selber sagt der übelste und
wider der hetze und diese wohnungen sind
jetzt durchsucht worden weitere handys
werden jetzt in den nächsten stunden und
tagen ausgewertet und die befürchtung
ist dass noch weitere teilnehmen dieser
check gruppen bekannt werden man muss
allerdings dazu sagen es handelt sich
hier um rein private gruppen dieser
polizei war aber dass es in dem fall
komplett egal
deswegen wird auch disziplinarrechtlich
ebene suspendiert eben mit dem ziel sie
aus dem dienst zu entfernen den
polizisten haben einfach die pflicht
anzeige zu erstatten wenn sie von so
etwas kenntnis bekommen sie haben den
sogenannten strafverfolgungs zwang auch
im privatleben und das heißt auch nur
die mit gelesen haben es handelt sich
insgesamt auch um 15 personen die nur
mit gelesen haben
aber das ist erstmal egal sie sind
genauso suspendiert mussten ihre waffen
abgeben und dürfen die diensträume auf
weiteres nicht
wir betreten wir sind bild und wir
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren